yo soy el propietario de este cultivo no
me quise acoger al programa penis porque
vi que no era un programa muy viable ni
muy satisfactorio viendo de que ya en
otras zonas donde se implementó el tenis
fue un fracaso y un total en
cumplimiento con los acuerdos de paz de
2016 unas 99 mil familias se
inscribieron al programa nacional de
sustitución de cultivos de uso ilícito
open y para erradicar voluntariamente
las plantaciones a cambio de subsidios
james murillo líder comunal del
municipio de calamar en el departamento
colombiano del guaviare no aceptó y
desde hace 20 años sostiene a su familia
gracias al cultivo de coca luís eduardo
vaca es cocaleros y se unió pero cinco
años después se siente engañado muchas
familias nos acogimos a este tema
pensando que era un
algo bueno para nosotros como campesinos
y fue todo un fracaso el gobierno nos
incumplió el trabajo de los campesinos
va desde las plantaciones hasta la
producción de pasta base de coca
convertida en cocaína por los
narcotraficantes así surgió una economía
ilícita que permite a los locales
subsistir durante el conflicto armado
ante el abandono estatal y el gobierno
decía que no puede invertir en estas
zonas porque estaba en la guerrilla de
las farc hoy en día tienen unos acuerdos
de paz y al igual el gobierno aquí no no
invierte sin infraestructura vías ni
servicios dignos la sustitución de coca
no fue como se esperaba sólo el 2 por
ciento de los proyectos productivos
funcionan muchos los cocaleros se
encontraron en la ganadería una
alternativa pero ha incrementado el
ritmo de deforestación en esta región
amazónica tumbar bosque y vender pasto
para el ganado es el negocio más
rentable en la zona sólo a ganar yo
juego una de las cosas que el mismo
gobierno nos incentivó a nosotros para
que dejáramos la coca y hoy en día al
ver el fuego de estación no es así y
entonces al paso que vamos nos va a
tocar volver a sembrar otra vez copa
edílson pinto se las ingenió cuando vio
que la ayuda del estado no funcionaba
cambiando la coca por el turismo
reconozcan que estará la realidad que
está la economía hacen un poco años que
se vio acá en el departamento no sólo
les voy a decir en otros departamentos
en su finca mantiene el laboratorio
donde elaboraba la base de coca aquí
muestra los químicos que lleva esta
pasta eso lo que hay que fundir a la
sociedad si dale a conocer porque hay
gente que consume pero no sabe que lo
que están consumiendo su vida de un giro
y ya no teme el sonido de las avionetas
militares que lanzaban glifosato para
erradicar forzosamente los cultivos
había una presión había nada soft una
preocupación pues era como una terapia o
sea no se puede ir como tranquilo pese a
todos los esfuerzos los cultivos de coca
colombia aumentaron un 7% en el último
año según la onu mientras el eslabón más
empobrecido en el negocio de la droga
los campesinos continúa sufriendo todas
las violencias en sus territorios